mm-hmm
and yeah we're going to get a handshake
there we go yes against Prague what a
game
no fantastic game yeah it definitely
featured some mistakes in the early
running Prague or maybe did not react to
uh the opening novelty in the best in
the best fashion found himself in a bit
of a rut and honestly
I want to kind of
retract those statements because in this
entire game
the only two moves I want to criticize
are Bishop 500k8 yeah because we know
that black for some reason is not even
worse after Rook C8 here because they
told us so and then after Bishop F5
Queen D1 already the position is
difficult you maybe just have to admit
you were wrong and put it back and
rookie 8 was pretty much losing tonight
of seven we we do know that is true yeah
but uh his reaction to this before
was maybe not the most ambitious but it
was definitely sensible
and if this position is not worse
why should we be too sharply critical of
what he's done in the run-up to it and
once again once once this position
appeared on the board
I think
it was just perfect he played it
absolutely perfectly
and he deserves a huge amount of Praise
in the context of the tournament
situation on the back of